Hello Freak bitches.
Listen,
the fucking,
the NBA had that mobbed up ref and he said that he fucked the warriors out and I
mean the,
uh,
the kings out of that series against the Lakers.
No one's going to take the fucking Lakers title away for that year.
Really?
Is that real?
Yeah.
What is it?
He was a referee.
Who's fucking fixing games?
Yup.
Really?
That's how much you don't watch.
No,
it was fit him Donna.
He 100% of NBA refs gamble.
What,
what?
But he's also like,
he's in jail now.
He's just trying to say shit,
but like I know this is the guy that was the rough that was in jail.
Yeah,
but like he,
he sat him right there.
Yeah.
He fixed gay.
He used to say from in jail.
He goes,
you tell me who was reffing the game and I'll tell you who wins.
Wow.
He spent 15 months in prison after pleading guilty of two charges of case he's
out freedom.
How much do you think he made?
He joined Callen Co Colin Cowherd,
Wednesday afternoon had a fascinating answer when asked what percentage?
He said 100 wow,
that's,
no,
nope,
not true.
That's just the fucking jail bird talk at.
I used to gamble on UFC fights way back in the early days when I first started
working for them.
I was like,
who gives a shit?
I can't really affect the outcome.
So like in many,
many years ago,
like I would,
they would,
they'd bring in these guys,
like they'd bring in some guy from like Brazil that I knew about and I would
look at the line and I'm like,
you guys are out of your fucking mind.
This guy should be like a 10 to one favorite and you got them at an underdog.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I'm putting some money on that.
And I'd put some money on it.
But then after awhile it's like,
this is probably not smart.
You know?
I don't think it's illegal because I can't stop it for the company.
No.
It's also not good for me if I come off as biased anyway.
You know,
I've been accused of being a biased commentator anyway.
Even worse,
he tap out,
c'mon,
c'mon.
Yeah.
But,
um,
that's a,
that's a different kind of thing though.
Gambling when you're a referee is a big deal.
Yeah.
And that's a game that's easily fixed.
How do they fix it?
What do they do?
Because you can,
you can take stars out of the game by giving them files.
Oh,
is that what they did?
Yeah.
Mobbed up guy.
Just you just sit people down.
It's just like if you're the best player on the team and the first quarter I
give you two quick fouls,
I'm not going to see you again until the second quarter.
And I've never fixed a fucking game.
But I mean,
I'm just,
you know,
I give you another one in the second quarter.
I don't see it til the next half and at some point you're going to get mad if I
keep calling bullshit files,
I might get you in a technical foul that saves me a ticky tack file that counts
towards your files.
And then two files,
two tacticals,
you're out of the game.
You're objected.
So was it obvious that this guy was doing files?
That it was great because the NBA was kind of fixed for a while.
Like I was sitting going like,
yeah,
I just,
I went to a game,
what time?
The Celtics First Utah Jazz and I'm watching the fucking game and like,
just like the game starts that letting them play and then they call it a tight
and then they're letting them play.
Then they call and a tight and it's like there was never an ebb and flow and how
they will call in the game.
It's like a,
an umpire,
you know,
you've seen the first day and it got to step out of the box going,
okay,
that's a strike tonight.
Okay,
cool.
Just finding out where you strike zone is.
But like an umpire,
if you start changing the strike zone,
kind of change in sports on your hair.
But it's like people are going to know like what the fuck's going on?
You gotta be consistent.
So like with um,
NBA reps,
we,
NBA Games,
you would watch and it's just like,
oh,
they're calling it close tonight.
Oh,
he's letting the boys play.
And like,
that was the game.
They wouldn't just keep,
obviously if it got really out of hand,
they would tighten down.
But I never saw a game where it was just like you're pulling back on the range,
you letting them run,
you pull it back,
you letting them run.
And it just made me feel like they were shaving points of something.
I'm a for years,
I said the game was fixed and um,
everybody said I was out of my fucking mind.
And then they find a guy who's all mobbed up and I go,
damn vindication.
They go,
oh,
it's just one guy.
Now when you say mobbed up,
like how was he mobbed up?
What was,
what was the issue with darker?
I just an expression,
I don't want to get in trouble with anybody,
but he was basically working for other people that were part of a gambling that
took,
uh,
you know,
bookie.
So whatever.
Right.
And he did something to make sure that the,
the game leaned in that direction.
Like you couldn't totally fix it.
Yeah.
So if a team was favored by eight and they want him to win by eight,
he'd make sure it happened are probably,
it's probably easier to make sure they didn't buy fucking over there on offense
and then they would just,
you know,
they try to get money,
like,
look,
if you're a legit bookie,
all you're trying to do is get an even amount of money on each side.
Okay.
Because with the combination of people tease in it and plus the juice and all of
that,
you're going to end up on top.
You don't want a bunch of money all on one side and losing your fucking shirt.
So what these guys would do is you get greedy after awhile.
It's like,
I'm sick of this ticky tack Shit.
Let's go for a big fucking score.
And they wouldn't do it every game.
They just,
every once in a while be like,
all right,
listen,
here's a game.
Probably,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know.
I've never fixed the fucking game.
I'm just guessing how they would go about doing it to fix this one.
All right.
Make sure these guys don't win by.
So this guy had meant that he fixed it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He went to was somebody went to jail for gambling on it.
Right.
But I went to jail phones fixing her,
fixing it.
So what,
what did he say?
He said like he made files that weren't really fouls.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
You do whatever he had to do.
This is what it is.
Uh,
attorneys submitted saying the manipulation that happened during one game.
Okay.
So it was officiating a playoff series between team five and team six in May of
2002 as a six game of a seven game series and a team five victory that night
would have ended the series.
However,
Tim learned from referee a that referees a and f wanted to extend the series of
seven games.
Tim knew referees a and F to B company,
men in quotes,
uh,
always acting in the interest of the NBA.
And that night it was in the NBA is interest add another game.
So the NBA wanted to fix it.
Yeah.
Follow the NBA,
fixing referees.
A and F heavily favored team.
Six personal fouls resulting in obviously injured players were ignored even when
they occurred.
Full view of the referees.
Conversely,
the referees called made up fouls on team the highlights of the Lakers kings
game.
It was ridiculous.
The files that they will come,
but that's my thing is when they said it was just one guy,
it's like how long could you be on an officiating crew while the in one of your
guys is dirty before you'd realize like what the fuck is this guy doing?
Well,
what about the guys that we're betting on the other team?
I'd want to kill that fucking referee.
You imagine if you saw him call fouls,
it weren't really fouls and [inaudible] was going on.
You knew your money was going out the window,
but I think they're really susceptible to it because like the amount of money
that NBA players make us fucking insane,
right?
They make like,
you know some of the contracts that they have coming up in this and so does so
few guys on the team and there's like every year the draft is like two rounds in
the draft.
Like fucking NFL goes on forever is 40 something guys on a team in the NFL.
There's 20 something in baseball,
20 something in,
uh,
in the NHL.
And I think,
I think basketball,
it's no more than 11 or 12 guys.
So it's a very small group of people and the income that they're generating,
like their revenue share,
I don't know how I,
like,
it's all that's all like super sports nerd shit.
Like,
I don't know how that works,
but some of the contracts that they,
that some of these guys have been signed in and like,
they can afford to fucking pay that guy that.
So now you're a ref and you're running with your fucking black aerobic Reebok
sneakers up and down the court,
you know the Velcade.
Yeah.
Yes.
And just seeing the cars these guys are getting in and all the women hanging out
and you're on the stage two,
you're running up and down.
No one gives a fuck about you.
And A,
I dunno what the pension is for the NBA,
but like if I was in the NBA,
I w if I was running I'd be like,
we gotta fucking triple these guys' salary.
Is this the salaries of the players of the referees NBA player salaries for
right.
What about the referees though?
So look at that.
35 million a year for Lebron.
That's just,
that's just what he makes the play hoop,
right?
Not about like most of,
most of the sneaker contracts are like more than what they make.
It's fucking nuts.
It's nuts.
It's a lot of cash.
Good for them.
I'm not,
I'm not like saying they should make the money.
Obviously if people are putting it out there earning the phone,
but like it can you put up what a ref makes.
Do you know who Mike Conley is?
That's what's hilarious.
I only know like the biggest guys at that Mike Kahn who that's my Conley.
Who fucks.
I don't know who that is.
Either.
Guy made $30 million last year was the highest paid player in the NBA.
He says because the contract is a guy named Mike Conley.
Yeah,
he was,
he's the starting point guard for the Memphis Grizzlies.
Yeah.
Oh,
there you go.
Let's find that amount of time.
Like his contract came up at the time last year and the uh,
when the rest of the guys are going to get more of this coming year and the
following year,
the TV contracts have gone up and there's a percentage of their going up each
year based off of the TV rights.
And that's why I watched almost every Celtic game last year.
I never heard my con,
my con,
that sounds like a fucking politician.
Which Ohio State Samuel was Greg Oden who was that big bust and he was just a
point guard.
Is he still playing in China or no?
No,
he's a actually Ohio state assistant coach right now.
He went back to school for playing in China.
That's when it gets weird.
Right.
And you got to go overseas to Europe and you playing for a hundred grand a year
and you're like,
Ooh,
I don't know.
Sometimes if you're famous enough,
they'll,
they'll give you a little more.
I don't know how that works either.
I don't know how to,
a lot of shit works.
I just know I have a show coming out called F sister's family.
That's why I'm here.
The average salary,
that'd be a reference from 150 grand to 550 grand.
That's a big spread.
What about the guy who was making the extra four?
How's he getting an extra four average salaries of spike considerably since 1983
when NBA officials may between 18,070 8,000 each season.
550 grand is not bad.
That's a lot of scratch.
So you'd have to give them enough money where they don't feel tempted to cheat.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the problem with politicians,
right?
You make 550 grand a year,
you're making 50 grand a year more than the president.
So you kind of like,
those guys are like set up to be like,
here's a job that cost 100 million to get and you're going to get paid 500
grant.
So could you just setting them up to have to cut deals with people.
Okay.